have you spoken to sharon osborne since
the last
time you guys were on set together no no
don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
no i can go back as far as i can go no
sharon took to dailymail.com to refute
the claim made on the sheryl underwood
radio podcast
for me it's about trust our source says
cheryl was asked on the podcast if the
two had spoken
and cheryl's answer remains no as to why
she didn't respond to sharon's text
our source says quote there was an
active network investigation
and she was very hurt and was working
through her emotions
i don't want anybody here to watch this
and say that we're attacking you for
being racist
i think it's too late i think that's
already sown
i still love the osbornes from what
i i've known of them i'm not saying i
liked being treated the way i was
treated
it was a trauma the talk will return
without sharon monday after a nearly
month-long hiatus
our source says cheryl feels no ill will
towards her former co-host
and cheryl says she can understand why
sharon walked away
there was part of me that felt like she
had to do the best for herself and her
family
she had to do the best for her life
you